Hello everyone, thanks for joining us. My name is Daph, I'm the creator of Verp Suite.
I'm going to talk today about AI in pen testing, how we're approaching it, and the new features
that have just landed in Verp Suite. While I'm talking, please post any questions that you have.
The link for posting questions should be in the chat. At the end, I'll try to answer as many as I can.
So, why AI for Verp and why now? Like most of the world, application security is at an inflection point with AI.
Applications are getting more complex, and so pen testing them effectively is getting more complex as well.
AI can handle a lot of grunt work, large volumes of data. It can automate more of the repetitive or the
mundane work than previous generations of automation were able to, leaving human testers to focus on the
critical stuff. Attackers have access to AI too. They can scale attacks and move faster than ever.
That means defenders can't afford to fall behind. Pen testers really need to take advantage of the
efficiency and scalability that AI provides.
Now, pen testers tend to be a skeptical bunch, and I come from the pen testing world as well.
Pen testers tend to be a little bit more complex.
I'm not sure if you're a little bit more complex, but I'm not sure if you're a little bit more complex,
but I'm not sure if you're a little bit more complex.
I'm not sure if you're a little bit more complex, but I'm not sure if you're a little bit more complex.
Just to say, hey, look, Burp's got AI. I'm pretty allergic to marketing fluff.
So it's vital for us that anything we put into Burp has to have substance, has to deliver
real value, has to be features that people actually want to use.
We're also pretty skeptical about any kind of black box magic.
So, hey, we've made a robo hacker that can do what skilled pen testers can do.
I wouldn't trust anything claims to do that because it certainly can't.
We're interested in using AI within your existing workflows in a way
that you can see what it's doing and you can work with it.
We're also very mindful of concerns about data handling.
So some people are doing crazy things, throwing sensitive data around, training on it,
piping untrusted input into powerful agents to perform actions.
We're security people. We're instinctively very cautious about that.
So if you're skeptical as well, we totally understand that.
We assume you will be skeptical until you see AI in action in Burp.
What we hope is that when you do see it in action, you will be as excited as we are
and that we'll earn your trust that we're going about this in the right way.
Our core philosophy is that automation is about augmenting human testers,
not replacing them.
When I first created Burp Suite more than 20 years ago, it was basically because I was a lazy pen
tester. I was doing a lot of boring, repetitive stuff, the same thing over and over, 100 times on
every test and then the same thing again on the next test and the next test after that.
I used to write Perl scripts to scale things up, send inputs to different parameters, cycle through
number ranges, things like that. That led to Burp Intruder so that I could set those up, set those
attacks up faster and more easily. Basically, the whole of Burp Suite's feature set over the following
years has been driven by that same philosophy, which is find the things that can be offloaded to the
machine and put those at the fingertips of the user. People often say Burp is the Swiss army knife
of pen testing. It's very much down to you which tools you choose for a particular task.
We approached AI with exactly that same philosophy. So we asked how can we use AI to make even better
power tools for pen testers to use in their workflows? Even with the very best classical
automation, there are still lots of repetitive things that people have to do. Because those tasks
need intelligence, they need an actual understanding of what's going on, how an application function is
supposed to work, what it's for, and the kind of things that might go wrong with it. What AI offers is
a generational leap in the kind of things that machines that can reliably, machines can reliably do.
So there's now a ton more things, quite boring, repetitive tasks that you can offload to the
automation, just like I did with Burp Intruder 20 years ago. You're still in control, you decide what
to offload. You basically have more options for where you focus your time and attention for the most
creative and critical tasks. So you can focus on the things that do need your expertise,
and that actually are the most fun and the most rewarding things to do yourself.
So with that philosophy in mind, how did we go about building AI? Like everyone else in 2023, our minds
were blown by what LLMs were capable of. We formed a small team working on the question, how could AI deliver
real value to pen testers? How could AI do for today's workflows what Burp Intruder did previously?
That team went broad. They came up with tons of ideas. Some great, some were crazy,
somewhat complete duds. They had quite an emotional roller coaster of optimism and despair, which was
funny to watch. Then later in 2024, we brought in more of our engineers. We had a bunch of AI hack weeks
where people played with some of the ideas, they added some new ones, and they figured out what could work.
We also began building out all the infrastructure that we'd need to deliver AI capabilities at scale
and creating a really robust testing ecosystem where we could road test different approaches with
different models and measure how well they performed. Technology was obviously moving pace around us,
so being able to quickly measure the progress in the technology and the progress that we were making
was vital. Towards the end of last year, we had a bunch of features working reasonably well,
and it was time to get these into the hands of users to see what they thought.
We then had a private beta with around 30 experienced Burp users.
We had a private beta users, and this was a real crunch moment, finding out if the features really
were valuable in the field, surfacing any concerns people had, seeing if our infrastructure could handle
real world usage at scale.
The feedback we got from the beta users was absolute gold. So they loved some things, they hated others,
they definitely weren't shy about telling us what they thought. There were some surprises where a particular
feature was way less useful or way more useful than we'd expected. We identified situations where the AI was
over-extended. Someone said it was like an eager junior pen tester, mostly helpful, but sometimes definitely
overconfident. That let us refine a bunch of things that was either to rein in what the AI was doing or to
push it further. We made some of the features more transparent so you could see more of how they worked
to get more trust that they were doing the right thing.
We absolutely stuck to our core philosophy. This had to be about valuable features that people
actually wanted to use and would trust. Definitely no gimmicks or black boxes.
And that brings us to today. So we've just launched this week the first set of five new features
for UpSuite to everyone. I'm not going to demo anything today, I think that'll be far too risky, but
I'll briefly describe each of those features. So the first is explore issue. So you can think of this
as an assistant that picks up where the scanner leaves off. When the scanner finds a potential issue,
you can use explore issue to dig deeper, validate the issue, demonstrate the impact, look for ways to
escalate it. It's like having an extra set of eyes that never gets tired of investigating findings.
So you can do things like generate proof of concepts, proof of concept exploits instantly, save you time.
It can uncover extra insights like leaked data or escalation paths, things you might, you might have missed.
It's great for gathering evidence you can use in pen test reports. And the key thing is that you stay
completely in control. So you decide when you set it running, you can see every step that it's taking,
you can follow its reasoning, what it's tried, what it's found, what didn't work.
You can intervene at any time, pick things up yourself manually, or just tell it to stop.
This feature was an absolute smash hit with our beta testers. For some issues like file disclosure
vulnerabilities, they would have spent a lot of time following up to go hunting the useful files.
Things like configuring intruder attacks, finding the right word lists, digging through the results.
You might be talking an hour or two of time to get the really the best proof of concept, the most
juicy disclosure. They found that explore issue did all of that in about five minutes.
The second feature is explainer. So this is really a quality of life thing.
When you're testing, if you're like me, you continuously run into things that you aren't
familiar with. You might see an obscure HTTP header or some parameter that looks like it's part of a UI
framework. You might see some JavaScript code that you don't really have time to dig into.
When you find yourself asking, what's this? You can use explainer to ask exactly that. Just select the
thing and explainer will give you a quick security focused explanation. Today's models basically have
all the knowledge that is out there. So it's like having a seasoned guru sitting next to you who can
immediately give you context on what you're looking at. This feature isn't actually super intelligent,
but it doesn't need to be. So we know from talking to users that many of you are routinely
pasting stuff into chat GPT and asking what's this explainer really just takes the grunt work out of
that. So you don't need to copy and paste. You don't need to alt tab. You don't need to write any prompts.
It keeps you in the zone where you are. Like I said, we didn't do this as a particularly
clever feature. It just does exactly what it says. What surprised us was how much our beta testers
loved the feature. They said that AI has sometimes turned them into a chat GPT monkey doing, they're
now doing a new monotonous thing, which is copying and pasting stuff back and forth to us what it is.
Explainer really just takes away that monkey work and inlines it for you.
The third feature is AI generated afforded logins. When you're testing an application with a login,
you need to configure the scanner to play well with that. You know the drill, you need to record a
login sequence so the scanner can authenticate reliably. Normally that means opening a browser,
clicking through login forms, dealing with single sign on or whatever. And that can be surprisingly
flaky. Sometimes you have to be really careful to get the steps precisely right so that Burps
automation can reproduce the login reliably. And that can take time, it can be frustrating.
With the new feature, you skip all of that. You just give Burp your credentials to the application
and it logs you in just like a human would. So in practice, it's a huge time saver and it gives you
better coverage in your test. If it's way easier to configure logins and the logins are reliable,
then you're much less likely to miss blind spots. This was a feature that our BC users raved about.
You take an app that always gives you headaches, which is really painful to get the login working
reliably. They said it just works. I don't know how it does it so much better than me, but I'm not
going back to setting it up myself. Now we can't promise that this will work perfectly every time,
but in 90% or more of situations, it should just work straight away.
The fourth feature is false positive reduction for access control bugs. False positives are obviously
pain in the ass. Any kind of automated testing brings with it the potential for false positives.
So we decided to tackle one of the trickiest categories of issue, which is broken access controls.
Testing for access control issues is still one of the areas that involves a lot of repetition and
monotony. A typical application might have dozens of functions that you need to test. There might be
different levels of privilege. You might have complex multi-step sequences where access controls can fail
at any point. As a tester, you often get a big matrix of things that you need to test and working through
all of those manually is really malicious. But it's also an area where automated tools in the past
haven't been able to do a very good job. This is something that we've worked on a lot over the years
of the past. Using classical automation, it's possible to fairly reliably detect when a function or an
action can be accessed in a particular user context. So the automation can tell whether or not you need
to be logged in to access it and who you need to be logged in as. What it hasn't been able to do previously
is tell you whether you should be able to access it as your current user. The machine couldn't tell the
difference between things that are sensitive and things that aren't. VerbScanner has had the ability
to test access controls for a long time, but it's never been reliably enough for us to really recommend
that people use it. And that's because of the limitations of that classical automation.
AI has been an absolute game changer for this. It can understand the purpose of an application function.
It can say fairly reliably whether the user should be able to access it. So it can filter the output from
the classical automation and get rid of false positives. Essentially, it knows what real access
control issues look like. The practical benefit is that it's a massive time saver on repetitive work.
You don't have to do everything by hand. You also don't have to dig through a ton of false positives either.
You can put more trust into the scanner, into the scanner output. So when it reports an access control
issue, you can have more faith in it. That means you spend more of your scarce time on the most valuable
tasks. Now, this really is just the start for us of using AI to reduce noise and scanning. We picked
access controls first because it's so prevalent and so painful to test for. We're going to extend this
approach to more vulnerability classes. So we'll be continuously improving that signal to noise ratio.
And the fifth feature is extensibility through the Montoya API.
We know that you guys are incredibly innovative in writing Burp extensions. You come up with all kinds
of features that we'd never imagined. So we've opened up Burp's AI ecosystem to the Montoya API.
This makes it really easy to invoke AI operations from your code. You don't need to write any boilerplate.
You don't need to handle API keys. You don't need to create UI to configure anything. It just works.
And for users, they can have trust that all the data is being handled securely. Everything goes
through our secure AI gateway. They just need to configure AI in one place. So if you have an idea
for using AI to add cool new features in Burp, definitely go for it. The Portswigger research team
have already been doing this. Gareth Hayes has added AI capabilities to supercharge
his HackVerser extension and he's added an AI assistant to Burp Repeater. Those are available
in the VAP store today. There are some AI powered extensions from the community that are also coming in.
Now, I mentioned at the beginning that lots of people are justifiably skeptical about AI and we've
shared that instinct. One area of concern is around data handling and privacy. What happens to your
highly sensitive data? We designed our approach to AI very much with those concerns in mind. So I'll
explain how we've gone about it. First, you're always in control. All of the features we've added are ones
that you need to invoke explicitly. So if you select some text and click explain this, then Burp will use AI.
So there's nothing silently processing your data in the background without you asking it to do.
Second, the AI models we use are not being trained on your data. They don't store anything. They don't
learn from anything. So if you select some text and click explain this, there is zero risk that your
data is ever going to be barfed out by an AI model hallucinating down the line. And it definitely isn't
going to end up in an open S3 bucket where DeepSeq stores all this stuff. Third, when your data is
processed by AI, everything goes through our secure infrastructure. We've documented exactly how your
data is handled. This platform is in scope for our bug bounty program. We're confident that everything
is handled securely. Fourth, there's a simple global kill switch in Burp for AI features in the settings.
If you don't want to use AI at all, ever in your workflow, then you can just turn off all AI functionality.
That will apply both for core Burp features and for BAP store extensions. If you do that, then Burp will
just act like classic Burp. Everything that worked before will still work. Nothing will be processed by AI.
We honestly won't be offended if you do that and turn it off, but we do think you might leave it on
once you see the value, once you see the benefits. Now, we do expect that attitudes to data handling
and AI will evolve in the same way that attitudes to cloud and SaaS evolved a generation ago.
People will gain confidence that data is being handled properly when the right protections are in place.
And when people see the value that AI adds, that will start to outweigh the concerns about data
protection. So if you're a consultant and your clients don't want you to start, don't want you to use AI
services today. That will change over time. Everything is ultimately about balancing different risks and
opportunities. Your adversaries obviously don't care about NDAs or your data. If they're using AI to get
an upper hand, then the risk calculation changes. You'll become more risky to not use AI and
your adversaries an unfair advantage. So just to wrap things up before going on to your questions.
AI is exciting. It's going to change everything, including AppSec. We really are at the start of a
new chapter, the pen testing. AI has got the potential to supercharge your work, take care of the boring
bits, letting you focus on the critical tasks that need a human. It's absolutely fine to be skeptical.
That's probably healthy. If you're worried about using it, remember that this is always about balancing
different risks. You don't want a risk being left behind. You don't want the most effective tools to be
only used by the bad guys. If you're like me, connect with your lazy inner self, give the features a try,
find the ways that they can let you offload the bits of your workflow that are least rewarding,
letting you focus on the fun parts. It doesn't have to cost you anything. We've given all BurpSuite Pro
users a bunch of free AI credits so you can try out the new features, just update the latest version of
Pro and you're good to go. And with that, I can see you've been posting a ton of questions and I will
do my best to answer as many of those as possible. So first up, will there be an option to use a local
LLM instead of the one provided by Portsweger? So our initial priority was to reach the maximum number
of users. Most users in reality don't have the means or the interest to use local models. For the models
we're currently using, it really wouldn't be feasible to run locally. It would be way outside
the compute capabilities of users' machines and that's orders of magnitude outside. Burp's Cloud AI
gateway can support access to numerous different models and we're able to choose the optimal model
for each task based on really extensive testing. So we can flex that over time as models and needs evolve.
Burp's capabilities and performance would be significantly reduced if we were tied to a single
model and probably a much less capable model if it was going to run locally. A few users
have asked us about this possibility and we're currently working to understand what's driving that
need, whether it's a need for offline air-gapped access, data protection concern, client NDAs, cost control,
anything else. Those conversations will make us better placed to plan our roadmap ahead.
Burp's capabilities are the same. So we're going to be able to do that.
Why can't users bring their own API key? Now, as I said, we flex between different models and even
different vendors for different tasks. We are having conversations with users to understand
needs that are driving questions like this. I think, as I said, our priority first was to get AI features into
the hands of as many users as possible, as quickly as possible. I think supporting the configuration
of users supplied keys for different vendors for different purposes would have added significant
complexity and would have slowed down those features for everyone. Another reason is, to be honest,
there's a lot of intellectual property in some of our capabilities and as a software vendor, we do need
to protect that and to monetize it appropriately so that we can continue to invest in Burp.
There's a question about using different models with the Montoya API and why BAPS can't use other AI
services if they want to. So the Montoya API gives access to the full Burp AI ecosystem and extensions that
go into the BAPS store have to use that. And that's for some of the same reasons why we insist that we
haven't allowed users to bring their own key. I think it could wreak havoc for data protection concerns if
there was a free for all in the extensions marketplace. You really don't want to be installing a random
BAPS and find out that it's just sending all your data to DeepSeq. So going through the Burp AI gateway
guarantees that all of the strong data protections that we have are in place. There's all data for
data retention and model training and secure handling. It would also be really bad UX users to have to
configure AI services for different extensions. We want a nice seamless user experience and we want the
Burp settings for turning off AI. They just have to work. So that's the reason why extension extensions
in the BAPS store have to go through that gateway. Also by controlling that gateway, Burp can give users
metrics and control over the AI spend of individual extensions. So you can see exactly what's going on.
Well, API usage by extensions is not a monetization strategy for us, so it won't cost any more.
And now as for private extensions that you might write yourself, extensions not in the BAPS store can
obviously do whatever they want. So if you want to write an extension for your own use, if you want
that to connect to any other AI services that you prefer, if you want to use a local model, that's
absolutely fine. They just won't be eligible to be in the BAPS store.
Okay. How are AI credits calculated? So we have, even though we have 10,000 credits free for
programs for now, how does this work? So yeah. So each time you use an AI power feature, it will consume
some credits and the amount of credits that are used will depend on the feature. So features like
explainer are really incredibly cheap to use. They cost virtually nothing. Other features that are
more involved and more heavy, it will obviously cost more. The majority of features as we build out in
the future, will have pretty fixed upfront known costs. So you'll be able to see every time I use this
feature, it consumes this many credits. Some operations are more open-ended and flexible.
If you think about the explore issue that that can be in principle open-ended and you can see the
progression of the thinking as it works through when you control whether it carries on, whether it stops
at any time. So it really will depend on the feature.
Is data being used to train any AI either by yourself or by other providers? No, there's no model training
from any of your data.
Can you give some examples of tasks or challenges that AI might struggle with even as the technology
evolves? Yeah. So today, AI isn't doing everything in Burp and we don't foresee a way for that
to ever be the case. I think the broadest category of an area where we still see the human need to play
a critical role is giving the direction to the work of AI. So for a well-defined task where the user
invokes it and says, for this particular thing, this is interesting. I'm going to need to invoke this
particular tool, this operation. It is working really well. AIs are not perfect, as we all know,
and they can go off track. And the more you chain together different operations and run those one
after another, the more scope there is for things to go wrong. So I think we see the human role as
being critical for that direction and that course correction, keeping an eye on what the AI is doing
and intervening where necessary. So it's like many self-driving features in cars where the, you know, you
still have manual controls and you can still intervene when necessary. We don't see a path with today's
generation of technology to produce a credible, fully autonomous pen testing bot that can replace a skill tester.
Do you see AI being more beneficial for experienced users or will it primarily be a helping hand for
people just learning about web app testing? I think it really is both, assuming both of them are lazy when
it comes to boring monotonous work. Certainly if you are, if you're near the start of your experience as a pen
tester, there might be more things where some of the AI powered operations are really able to do things
that you can't, that are not in your skill set. And that's a great way to learn because if you can see
how the machine will do some of these things, you then are going to start to understand more and learn
how to do them yourself. But even for, you know, highly experienced users, there are endless things that
you often need to do that are quite repetitive, that's, that really benefit from offloading to
automation to process information at scale to just be reliable covering, covering it, you know, a very
long list of places to check things like that. I think some of the, some of the abilities that we
foresee down the line to be able to join the dots between different things that are observed in
different places in an application, different points in application to chain operations together quite
imaginatively. We would expect that some of those things that the AI can suggest or recommend or
carry out will really benefit even, even the most experienced testers as well as being able to
offload boring things. Next question. Why did Portsburgr decide to wait till now to introduce AI
features? Well, this is really, as I described in the timeline, you know, we could
have gone much earlier and, you know, had a big splash launch of some fairly gimmicky feature to say,
look, you know, those got AI like, like everyone else. It was really vital for us that we features
we landed with delivering proper value that are going to be useful. And they were going to cut
through people's skepticism. So it was, it was important for us to kind of think broadly about all
the things that all the avenues we could pursue in that direction to, to try and achieve that and really get
that real world validation from, from our beta users as to what, what it was that was most useful.
That, that's why it's taken us up until now, but we have a lot of momentum. We've got a healthy roadmap
and we've got plenty of other things coming down, coming down the line.
Will AI come to Burp Suite Enterprise? Yes, we expect so. It'll be only some of the capabilities,
because obviously Burp Suite Pro is aimed at hands-on testing. So a lot of the kind of productivity,
the power tool things that integrate with your data testing workflow are not really applicable
in the enterprise context, but, but many of the, many things are. So two, two of the, the core features
that we've added, AI powered recorded logins and filtering of false positives for access control
issues are absolutely applicable in the enterprise context and extensions work in enterprise edition as
well. So we expect that, you know, we will get some more real world feedback from, from amazing pro users.
And then before long, these features will start to appear in enterprise as well.
Are you worried about Kaido? Good question. Well, I'm not, I'm not really a warrior. I think it's good to
have imitators out there. It keeps us on our toes. It definitely stops us getting complacent. There's room
in the world for more than one security tool, several security tools in web security. Lots of testers use a
combination of different tools for different situations. Burp Suite Pro is obviously an incredibly
powerful tool. And there's a reason why it's the tool of choice for most professional pen testers. You need
depth and precision. You need extreme configurability. You need proper coverage of protocols like HTTP2 and
WebSockets. You need rock solid out of the out of band testing with the collaborator. You need cutting
edge tools like banders, which give you full extensibility right in the UI. You need core automation
that's been shaped by decades of the best pen testers and the best web security researchers researchers in the world.
If you have your own ideas of how to make birth even better, we are always listening. So definitely get
involved with the conversations here on Discord.
What has changed since Portsburger was acquired by outside investors? Are you going to hike the price
like Nessus did? Well, firstly, Portsburger hasn't been acquired. Almost a year ago, we did get some outside
investment for the first time. The investor owns about a third of the business and I still own the rest.
So we haven't lost control of our destiny. After over 20 years of bootstrapping a business out of a hobby
project, getting investor was obviously a huge decision. We thought about this very carefully.
We were exceptionally choosy about who will be our investment partner. It was critical that we found a
partner who fully aligned with our vision. That means a long-term perspective, belief in product excellence,
strongly engaged with our community, ambitious but not greedy. We turned away a ton of people who were
absolutely desperate to invest in Portsburger and offering really silly money because they weren't
aligned with our vision and they would try to make us change course. Lots of people said a bunch of
reassuring words but then insisted that they wanted a majority shareholder. I was obviously pretty
skeptical about those people. I think the best signal that someone is genuine and not wanting to change
course is that they are happy for us to remain in control. So that was the non-negotiable. We've been
working with our investor, BPC, for nearly a year and it's really been fantastic. They bring us a wealth of
expertise and experience. Scaling a business is really hard. I've never done it before. Most of the
Portswiga team haven't done it before. As we grew and things got more complex, there was a real risk that
we were going to screw up. We were going to make some bad mistakes and so we were going to fail on our
mission, which is basically to enable the world to secure the web and have great fun along the way.
The best thing about BPC is that they recognized that Portswiga had something special. They didn't
want to change that. Great products that users love and engage community, not greedy or selling out.
They've been happy to work with us to retain all of that while getting a bit more organized and
professional than we were. But it's still the same people in control and making decisions. So no,
we're not going to hike the price. We're not going to get rid of our amazing free output like the academy
or our research. We absolutely love our community and we're not going to do anything that burns that.
In fact, we're only going to get more engaged. In the past, we've never stepped up to doing proper
in-person events to meet our users and give back to them. That's definitely one thing that is going
to change now that we have the support to do it really well. So watch this space.
What are some of the questions that you've asked? What's next with it and AI? Well, I'm not going to
reveal any of the details of upcoming features other than to say we've got at least as many
awesome ideas being actively thought about and worked on as we've been able to release so far. So this is
going to turn into a really rich roadmap. There's scope to do things like false positive reduction
across quite a wide variety of different vulnerability classes. There's scope to make
a lot of automated operations a lot smarter with genuine understanding of the functionality and the
meaning of the content that we run into in applications. There's absolutely scope to take
monotonous work off you guys for reporting your findings and writing them up for clients,
a ton of other things. So we'll be, we'll definitely be talking about more about those before long.
Integrating AI into security testing methodology. And my current challenge has been learning how to do
security testing in AI. Do you have any suggestions around how best to learn? Well, a good place to start
is the Web Security Academy. So we have a bunch of LLM based labs that have real vulnerabilities in that
are quite representative of what you might run into in the real world. That is a great place to play and to
learn. This is such a rapidly shifting area. So I think just consuming all the output from all the usual
sources that people are talking about. I think it's a kind of area where if someone wrote a book about
about doing hacking of AI, AI based features by the time it was written, it would be obsolete. So this
is just something to really lean into your, your learning mindset and go and play, go and find out
for yourself, go and read all the, all the sources of wisdom that are out there.
How can I get into the private beta testers group? Well, we, we aren't currently doing that exercise
right now, but I'm sure we will be doing it again in future. If you want to be considered,
just email us at trials.portspot.net to express an interest. And we will absolutely
be talking to you about taking part in future trials.
I think we've covered nearly everything in the duplicates.
Where does the name Burp Suite come from? Well, there isn't a profound answer to this.
I, like I said, I started working on Burp Suite over 20 years ago, and it was just for me. It was a
a bunch of little tools that I was, I was just writing to help me do my own job better and put
them together into this thing called, called a suite, a suite of tools. Every software project has a
name and, and I didn't give much thought at all. I can't even remember why that word came to my head
that day. There was no, no significance about it. It just ended up sticking. And, you know, I was actually
in the habit of writing lots of different tools in different languages, and most of them being fairly
disposable. And they all had silly names like that. So it was just a bit of an accident, a bit of a
fluke that Burp Suite was the one that ended up enduring and, and surviving the tool you know and love
today.
Hey, I think that's pretty much all the questions. So yeah, thank you for listening. Thank you for
asking those. They were really good. Do try out the pay for yourself. Use the free credits. Absolutely.
Let us know what you think. Talk to us directly. Talk on our Discord community here. We have some other
upcoming events over the next couple of weeks. You can meet some of the Burp Suite developers. You can
meet the research team. That's James Kettle and Gareth Hayes. Thank you all very much for joining.
Thank you.